It's most likely Hsiao-Lu isn't transcribing or translating
her gene as an adult. Even though she
could as a child. This would result in
a decrease lactase activtiy, but increase lactose intolerance symptoms.
>> >Exactly the reason it's not likely she has
a mutation or an allele of the lactase gene that
doesn't work or is non-functional. Is because we know she
could digest lactose products as a baby, if she had
a lactase gene that didn't work at all, then she would also not have been
able to drink milk as a baby. Which would have been problematic in general. So
the fact that she could drink milk as a baby means that its most likely
that she has a functioning lactase gene but its just turned off, as an adult.